los londinenses siguen depositando
flores y haciendo homenajes a las
afueras del palacio de bukingham tras el
fallecimiento del príncipe felipe pero
nada ha sido como en las últimas décadas
cuando murieron otros miembros de la
realeza y no porque los británicos
sientan menos cariño por el duque de
edimburgo sino porque la familia real ha
instado al público a evitar
aglomeraciones debido al cob y 19 aún
así muchos presentaron sus respetos
hemos venido a llorar con la reina y
todos y sabemos que no hay nadie más
triste que la reina eso lo sabemos y
sabemos que la reina tomo sus manos
mientras él se iba con dios lo hemos
perdido un gran hombre y él ha dado
tanto por lo que se merece los tributos
mucho mucho más tributo de lo que
realmente le estamos dando pero no todo
el mundo está devastado por la muerte
del príncipe felipe quien tenía 99 años
y cuya salud había empeorado
recientemente de monarca hachemí no soy
monárquico la muerte del príncipe felipe
si bien puede ser una tragedia para su
familia no tiene sentido en mi vida
a medida que la sociedad hace una
introspección en las cuestiones del
racismo entre las personas en la prensa
y dentro de la familia real algunos
recordaron las controversias sobre
antiguos comentarios hechos por el
principio
algunos de ellos han tenido un tono un
poco más racista lo que es menos
perdonable pero creo que todo eso debe
equilibrarse con la visión general de
los oakland debido al kobe 19 se está
revisando la organización del funeral ya
que actualmente sólo 30 personas pueden
asistir a estas ceremonias es probable
que se limite a familiares cercanos se
dice que el propio príncipe quería un
funeral discreto